foreign
[Music]
have predicted that this guy could be
the next president so he was a wealthy
businessman before getting into politics
he became team governor of anambra state
and will be seen as candidate of the
youth a fresh face even though he's 61
but then he's relatively young compared
to the others
hola I'm at Singapore widely considered
to be the most influential political
Godfather in Nigeria today and he was a
two-time governor of Lagos he was also
senator for a brief time between 1992
and 1993. many people say he's a
candidate fit
foreign
between 1999 and 2007. this is the sixth
Run for the presidency dating on the way
back to 1993 and it's worth remembering
that the current President muhammadu
buhari also ran multiple times before
winning
rap Universal focus of many people see
him as a wildcat but he was an
influential former governor of Kano
state a step with the highest number of
registered voters in Nigeria and if this
election goes on to a second round it
will be partly because of him and he
will be the deciding factor ahead of our
second round so this election is really
too close to call which is why many
pundits have predicted the possibility
of a runoff which could be the first one
in Nigeria's political history
foreign